digamos que tenemos la variable
aleatoria x que es igual al número de
perros que veo hoy y la variable
aleatoria que es el número de gatos que
veo hoy y digamos que también conocemos
cuál es la media de estas variables
aleatorias el valor esperado el valor
esperado de x que también podemos
denotar como la media de x decimos que
hoy esperamos ver tres perros de forma
similar para los gatos decimos que el
valor esperado de iu es la media de g y
decimos que hoy esperamos ver cuatro
gatos en vídeos anteriores definimos
cómo calcular la media o el valor
esperado de una variable aleatoria ahora
vamos a pensar en cuál será el valor
esperado de x + o también podemos decir
cuál es la media de x + ya resulta que
aunque no lo estoy demostrando en este
momento la suma de la media de variables
aleatorias es igual a la suma de las
medias de dichas variables esto es igual
a la media de la variable aleatoria x
más la media de la variable aleatoria
en este caso particular si yo quisiera
saber cuál es el valor esperado de
perros y gatos que veré en cierto día
entonces su madre estas dos medias será
34 que nos da 7 de forma similar si yo
quisiera saber cuántos gatos más voy a
ver en cierto día en comparación con la
cantidad de perros que beret o el valor
esperado de menos x a que será igual
intuitivamente ustedes me pueden decir
que el valor esperado de la suma es la
suma de los valores esperados entonces
el valor esperado de la diferencia de
las medias será la diferencia de las
medias lo que es correcto esto es igual
a la media de menos x que es igual a la
media de james menos la media de x y en
este caso en particular es 4 menos 3 que
es igual a 1 otra forma de pensar en
esto intuitivamente es que yo espero ver
un gato más que la cantidad de perros
que espero ver en cierto día el ejemplo
que acabamos de usar involucra variables
discretas no podemos decir que en cierto
día veremos dos puntos dos perros y
perros el valor esperado en sí mismo no
tiene que ser un número entero ya que
podemos promediar lo en varios días pero
es la misma idea de que la media de la
suma es la suma de las medias y que la
media de la diferencia es igual que la
diferencia de las medias veremos la
demostración de esto en un futuro vídeo